foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker's CBS Westwood one color
analyst host of Ross Tucker football
podcast he was on the sidelines
yesterday the Eagles and the Niners and
by the way joining us on behalf of
DraftKings Sports books sing game
parlays you can pocket more cash when
you combine multiple bets from one game
download the app sign up with the code
Patrick get a special offer restriction
Supply see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details Ross joins us what did you see
on the Brock Purdy injury
well I was surprised Dan I mean I'm on
the Niner sideline I usually spend most
of the time on the visiting sideline
because there's less people over there
and because that's how you get more TV
time because all the cameras are where
the Press Box is on the home so I
intentionally go on the away side to try
to get as much TV time for my sister and
my daughters as I can
um but no I mean you could tell he got
hit right obviously we all saw that but
when he was throwing on the sideline he
was throwing okay I mean he wasn't like
really zipping it in there but he's
doing okay I thought I saw him Dan look
at some people and say you know kind of
Nod his head and say yeah I'm okay and
then
the Niners come out for the next series
and Josh Johnson goes out there it's a
TV timeout and I'm you know so we're not
on radio either so I tweeted Josh
Johnson's in the game of quarterback and
I went over there I was right behind
Purdy they were like rubbing some type
of bomb on his bicep and bicep tendon
they were doing something with the back
of his elbow I mean they did everything
they could to try to enable that kid to
go back in the game and throw but at
halftime when I was walking off the
field with Kyle Shanahan Aaron Andrews
Aaron said what about Purdy in the
second half and Kyle said I'm told it's
a no so he was not supposed to come back
in the game obviously until Johnson got
hurt and then I think Kyle just thought
he'd rather have a guy that could at
least take the snaps from Center and
hand off than try to put use Checker
McCaffrey or somebody back there yeah
trying to figure that out I was
surprised they just didn't stay with
Devo or McCaffrey in the wild Wildcat
and you know Purdy said I couldn't throw
the ball 10 yards Johnson gets the
concussion there the game plan for the
Niners in the second half uh what did
you make of that
well I thought it was sad I mean I'm on
the Niners sideline McCaffrey had one of
the best touchdown runs I've ever seen
that was unbelievable Debo Samuels over
there Dan asking to return punts and
kickoffs trying to get the Niners back
in this and they have so many good
players such a good team but they
obviously had no chance at that point
and you know
I don't think they really have that much
in the playbook in terms of Wildcat like
it sounds great to say yeah just put
McCaffrey out there and run the Wildcat
but they don't actually practice that
you know if they thought that that was a
possibility then they would have had a
third quarterback active for the game
you know they don't think two
quarterbacks are gonna get hurt so
there's a lot there and I know Dan you
remember when I played 45 guys were
active
eight of us you know were inactive and
then there was one guy that was the
emergency quarterback that could only go
in the game if the first two got hurt
and once he went in the first two
couldn't they don't have that anymore
they bumped the rosters up to 48 so the
Niners made a choice not to have a third
quarterback out there I don't blame them
that's what most teams do I will say
this the last thing I'll say about this
as much as it stunk because you know the
game was kind of over then
you know it sounds weird to say this in
the context of a sport but this is
football the Eagles earned those
injuries I mean Reddick hit pretty hard
on the elbow when it was back like that
and by the way Kyle Shanahan why are you
having tight ends block Hassan Reddit
what why are you doing that and then you
know I think it was Sue I can't remember
who hit Josh Johnson so the Eagles
d-line it was not like those were fluke
injuries the Eagles d-line caused those
injuries yeah I was wondering about that
as a former offensive lineman when you
got somebody like Reddick where you need
help do you say look I need help do you
say that to your coach do you say that
to your quarterback that I can't handle
this guy one on one
well so first of all
they had tight ends trying to block him
or they were trying to do this play
action and boots and having tight ends
and receivers block him which was it
didn't work obviously
um usually Dan they kind of know that
ahead of time in terms of whether or not
you would struggle with a guy one-on-one
pass but what they'll do is they'll
actually give you some help early in the
game to let you get settled in whether
they Slide the center your way or they
chip or you know whatever to get you
comfortable and then maybe try you
one-on-one sometimes you know I don't
think I ever said to a coach or I don't
think I ever heard a guy say to a coach
you know I need help usually the coach
identifies that before the player is
willing to say that
there are certain guys that have
deceptive speed
Reddick and Bosa like you don't realize
how much quicker they are off the ball
than everybody else and it like Reddick
was that was alarming how quick he felt
uh I don't know if you see it the same
way when you're on the sidelines but it
just felt like wow is she a half a step
faster than everybody else well you know
what's wild about him this is his third
straight year with double digit sacks he
did it in Arizona in 2020 in Carolina
2021 you would be amazed at he's not
even a finalist for defensive player of
the year I'm amazed how many people
don't even know who Hassan Reddick is
but he's a Camden kid which is right
across the river from Philly like he's
been waiting his whole life for
yesterday I was thrilled for him now at
least everybody knows who Hassan Reddick
is yeah now there was a moment on the
sidelines where I think Miles Sanders
goes out of bounds in 2 9 over there
looked like they were going to get into
a little bit of a back and forth and you
backed up and then you started to walk
almost in the middle of this like you
were going to engage with the 49er what
what the hell were you doing oh yeah I
have a whole strategy for this Dan so so
first of all okay
some of the people on the sideline have
no clue if it ever looks like a running
back or wide receiver quarterback is
running towards the sideline when they
get to the numbers you need to get back
these people on the sideline being like
Oh la de da yeah they're 10 yards away
dude you have no time they are on you
like this then I have no interest in
getting hurt no interest in the torn ACL
because I when they get near the numbers
I run backwards but you backed up but
then you you started coming up yeah yeah
that's for the TV time oh that's for my
close-up oh that's for the close-up well
you I was gonna wear my orange ski
jacket so that everybody so I get a lot
of TV time yeah but my wife said what if
like that's very unprofessional looking
everybody else wears something nice
you're gonna have an orange ski jacket
that just for TV I was like yeah you're
probably right so uh but no I get back
and I immediately get right back in to
try to get I was getting Charlie Weiss
texted me that he saw me like I was
getting texts from everybody I got I got
like three or four five second Clips
yesterday I think yeah well done we're
talking to Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst uh the referees in the
Bengals Chiefs game had what kind of
impact on the outcome
not nearly as much of one as people are
saying today
they were not good it was disappointing
the extra down on third down was
horrific
but the chief still punted
you know Dan can you imagine
if the Chiefs went down for a touchdown
after that that would be the only thing
we'd be talking about today thankfully
for everybody involved but they changed
field position Ross
they kept the drive alive yeah I mean
look you run the clock you got you know
there you didn't score you kept the ball
kept the clock moving and you changed
field position so it did there might
have been a uh you know some kind of end
result because of that and the result
shouldn't matter they they didn't blow
the play dead which I don't understand
how they couldn't do that let the play
go sorry that play counts
I agree the one back judge or whoever
they showed on the wide all 22 that he
kind of ran in right was that to me they
should have let that play Go
I will say this to all the Bengals fans
saying the NFL is rigged or whatever
like hey Bengals fans do you think the
NFL wanted to be Bengals Rams in the
Super Bowl last year and by the way if
it's rigged didn't they rig it for you
last year like that doesn't even make
any sense it's obviously not right
here's the thing though Dan that was bad
and I totally agree with what you just
said
the Bengals had the ball twice Thai game
and they didn't get it done I mean they
had the one pick that burrow through
where the cook for the chiefs made a
good play then the next Drive Chris
Jones sacks Joe burrow twice Bengals had
the ball tie game they weren't able to
get it done
the Chiefs make it sound like they blew
out the Bengals you know with all of
this post-game celebration and Travis
Kelsey and Patrick Mahomes us against
the what the hell happened here you guys
barely squeaked by this you know the
Bengals at home you got the league MVP
even on one leg you got a Hall of Fame
tight end here you got a guy who's going
to be one of the three best defensive
linemen in football this year I mean
come on
and then they won the game on a
game-clenching unnecessary roughness
penalty yes yes
like I mean was that the first game
clenching on Necessary Roughness penalty
in uh NFL history I felt bad for that
kid by the way they kept showing him and
you can see his chest was like he's 22
years old I felt awful for him because
people don't know what it's like
imagine being 260 pounds you're running
as fast as you can you got a helmet on
you only have your line of Visions like
this you're running like this it's not
that easy to be able to know that
Mahomes is out of bounds that was
unfortunate but yeah you know the way it
is in pro sports day and you're looking
for any little motivation they didn't
like that they were calling it burrow
head stadium and look that game I said
this on the Ross tiger podcast this
morning that was a huge game
for Andy Reed and Patrick Mahomes Legacy
there's a big difference between three
Super Bowls in four years versus Owen
four against burrow Zack Taylor and the
Bengals I mean as great as they are Dan
you know this if you're Owen for boy
that hurts your argument in terms of
being you know an all-time great pairing
great to talk to you as always
man can't wait to see you next week it's
gonna be great and it's and it's a uh
jabroni not a jambrony as frizzy says it
right have you ever been called a
jabroni it's a jabroni yes that's from
The Rock
yeah fritzy said jambrony jam and
jambrony like the number one fritzy
supporter of anybody but then he does
things like that and he just puts me in
such a bad spot it's like indefensible
thank you Ross see man we'll see you in
Arizona Ross joining us on behalf of
DraftKings Sportsbook same game parlays
pocket more cash when you combine
multiple bets from one game download the
app sign up use the promo code Patrick
and you can see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details